[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
monday august 15th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
getting more electric vehicles on the
road means there's greater demand for
lithium batteries that power them
and getting more lithium means dealing
more often with an area of the world
called the lithium triangle a stretch of
land across multiple countries in south
america that has 55
of the world's known lithium deposits
but there's a catch
three actually
bolivia has almost no production of the
metal chile's new government is putting
the brakes on some projects and
argentina where the government has
promised to expand lithium operations
currently has only two mines experts are
warning these bottlenecks for getting
the mineral could slow the uptake of evs
worldwide
joining us to discuss why this is
happening and its global implications is
wsj south america reporter ryan dubay hi
ryan thanks for joining us thank you for
having me
i want to start by asking about a
chinese eevee company byd they had a
contract with chile to mine lithium but
the government canceled that can you
explain what happened here what was
behind that decision
sure so um in january of this year byd
won a contract it's part of an auction
to
mine lithium and chile
the government because lithium is a
strategic resource it doesn't give
concessions like it would for copper or
gold or other minerals so what it gives
is a production quota essentially
so after one dakota um some indigenous
communities who are concerned about the
use of water from lithium mining
they filed a lawsuit to try to overturn
it
it was suspended essentially
immediately almost after the auction was
awarded
and then in tune the supreme court ruled
on it and throughout the contract saying
that the auction wasn't valid
because the government had not consulted
with indigenous people first essentially
and a lot of these indigenous groups i
believe have brought up things like the
environmental impact what kind of
environmental impact does mining for
lithium have because mining for most
things has some kind of environmental
impact
yeah absolutely so lithium in chile is
found in the atacama desert which is the
driest place in the world
it's you know a moonlight landscape
surrounded by volcanoes essentially it's
spectacular views
but
the lithium is found
underground in brines which is salty
water essentially and so the companies
to extract the lithium they need to pump
up the brines
and they evaporate the lithium in the
sun in large man-made pools
so the indigenous people say are
concerned that the amount of water that
is extracted from underground from the
brines is such a quantity that affects
the lagoons and affects the wildlife in
those areas and it could affect you know
their farming essentially that they
survive on we talked about some of the
environmental issues i mean are there
other concerns coming from these
governments about the
mining of lithium or about the use of
this resource from their countries
yeah there's two other issues so one is
on top of the environmental issues
there's the issue of
you know communities that have lived
near minds for many you know other types
of minds for many years
have a history of living close to areas
where there's lots of natural resource
extraction they want to make sure that
they kind of benefit from that wealth
that is created and on the government
side as well
the economic history of latin america is
really marked by
the use of natural resources and the
debate is over how best to use those for
our society
so
on one hand it's you know the idea of
taking advantage of the resources to
mine them and to ship them out and
export them to other areas which creates
a lot of value locally as well but a lot
of you know politicians and other
government officials uh communities as
well they want to kind of industrialize
and have a bigger manufacturing sector
based on those natural resources right i
mean you mentioned kind of the the
demand for electric vehicles but lithium
also goes in other batteries and can you
give us a sense of how much demand there
is
for this mineral now and kind of how
that's been growing
sure so
today for example i believe the global
production of lithium is about 500 000
tons the demand has increased in the
last few years as electric vehicles
sales have increased
the main driver of
lithium demand is from electric vehicles
even though it's used for medicine for
health purposes as well as for
smartphones for example but in the next
decade or so electric vehicle sales is
supposed to increase by about 30-fold in
the next 20 years some figures i've seen
says that the demand for lithium will
increase up to about 40-fold how are the
companies that want to mine it and then
the companies i guess that need it down
the road dealing with those dueling
challenges of kind of rising demand
maybe rising competition for this
material and at the same time
governments that are maybe putting a
little bit more uh restrictions or being
a little bit more cautious about
granting mining contracts for lithium
sure so there are some companies that
are trying to develop new technologies
in order to
mine lithium without using as much water
and without the traditional process that
they use in south america which is the
evaporation process
but other companies i mean they they're
basically saying well we know we can't
develop it in bolivia so we're not going
to go there we know we can't you have a
really tough time developing it in chile
so we're not going to go there either
the one country in south america that
does have lithium that is kind of open
to investments at the moment is
argentina so many companies are going to
argentina
but argentina has a lot of macroeconomic
problems
you know inflation is about 65 right now
one of the highest in the world
they have restrictions on bringing
currency in on imports and that's a big
issue from companies that are you know
trying to mine a chemical that requires
a lot of technology to bring in a lot of
expertise to bring in as well
so the result essentially is that
lithium prices are increasing a lot
they're up about 750 percent
since the beginning of 2021
and the concern is that that'll make any
transition to renewable you know to
electric vehicles more expensive and
more difficult
all right that's our reporter ryan dube
thanks for joining us ryan thank you
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing
if you want more tech stories check out
our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts i'm zoe thomas for the
wall street journal thanks for listening
[Music]
you